[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation I'm curious how many
members the long now foundation are here
raise your hands
okay after the show you were supposed to
mop the stage and it will come up here
for the group photograph which you saw
one of just recently Thank You long now
members for helping keep our foundation
in operation from year to year if by any
chance you want to help keep it going
from century to century you may notice
on the back of your introduction card
some words about the fund that belong
now an endowment that we aim to set in
motion once there's a half a million
dollars there then we start going
thousands of years like universities do
if you're so inclined I mean somebody's
gotta tend the clock so for tonight
whenever San Francisco has a gold rush
it gets interested in discontinuity and
we are now but that's exactly the time
you want to be most interested in
continuity because one of the things we
keep learning it long now is as the
future keeps unfolding century after
century millennium after millennium the
past keeps unfolding and showing us new
things nobody's better at that than Rick
Prelinger
Thank You Stuart okay so many friends
and acquaintances you know I was going
to ask how many of you have been to all
10 shows but I can hardly see you are
there a few of you few been to all 10
shows how many for your viewers are here
for your first time Oh excellent
welcome so look this probably doesn't
need much of an introduction then I'm
gonna give you one anyway this is quite
unbelievably the 10th year after making
this film after making this film I
realized it might be a little gloomy er
than last year's but it's been a
gloomiest year in San Francisco I I
hasten to say don't worry because it's
also filled with life-affirming pictures
but now more than ever this event is
about the city that we would like to
live in that we want to live in as much
as about the city that was please try to
keep that in your mind a few special
thanks first and foremost the community
of San Francisco historians who makes
this possible who are the kind of growth
medium who put me in touch with folks
that have material who turn out in great
numbers etc special mention to Western
neighborhoods project and to their new
yeah and a shout out to their new
amazing still historical image site open
SF history org if you haven't visited do
and look I'd like to also give special
thanks to my partner and soul mate Megan
Prelinger
um I don't want to embarrass her but
from the very start she's been an
unwavering supporter of my work even as
she's pursued a complex research and
writing career of her own so she's
really made it all possible thank you
and my admonishment to all of you you
are the soundtrack this year the the
program is completely and utterly silent
so it's up to you to ask questions to
identify places people and events to
dispute the identifications of your
neighbor to engage in spirited in civil
discussion tweeting is encouraged
selfies are encouraged just don't blind
your neighbor have fun see you in 73
minutes thank you
[Applause]
this is about 1947 before our bridges
and even afterwards and now again we
have our ferries
Mattson line
this is a feature film outtake no idea
slowboat to Frisco I don't know so um
you've seen this before but never like
this this is a new 4k scan from Library
of Congress
yeah this is I I think the Western
Addition we're going to come up you'll
see either Venice or Franklin I believe
horses and bicycles you could try to
keep at least one of each
this was a hand-cranked 35 millimeter
film camera doing a very slow pan
[Applause]
Central freeway
this is the new Bay Bridge it's about
well ten years old
this is the 60s I think some of you may
recognize the new buildings that are
going up very late 60s Pacific telephone
the old gas station on Third Street
Transbay terminal sorely missed by some
of us
look at the clock on the bookstore it's
not really a clock it's a Triscuit de
Leon I think
the Muni and the Market Street Railway
cars
from the mid-30s
from tourist home movies 1944
the montage of ordinary people 50s 60s
and 70s these are outtakes from the
official San Francisco Convention and
Visitor's Bureau film sometimes they're
outtakes for a reason
this guy bought a Berkeley barb and
probably not for the activism stories
this is more time about 44 settling down
for a wild night so um this is inside a
bar I believe at kearney n market in the
30s about 1936-37 Reilly's cafe
and we're going to come back to the more
these are outtakes from guess who's
coming to dinner
and this is a background or four plate
for rear-projection and you can see that
it's ruined when people look at the
camera
[Applause]
this is material shot by one of our
local TV stations presented for the
first time in HD for a film about the
Salvation Army but this is what we now
call soma the third and Howard fourth
and Howard area looked like in somewhere
around 1953-54 and it shows some
desperation but it also shows a
community that in its own way was was
thriving
as many of you know this neighborhood
was leveled and stayed leveled for quite
a number of years until they finally got
it together to build yerba buena later
Moscone Center and now there's hardly an
inch of breathing room except that
little Park
one of the things I learned looking at
this material was that it was a many
many Greek owned businesses
I'm not sure what street that is
but that is that forth and Howard I
can't quite see from here
so they're listening to a preacher and
the Salvation Army band
one of the things that's interesting
about that film is that the camera
person didn't dwell on people's faces so
there was a sense of dignity to a lot of
those shots sometime in the mid to late
40s working waterfront freight traffic
on the streets of South of Market I
believe it is
so this was a film probably made either
by Hurst or path a around a time in San
Francisco 1916 a year before we entered
World War one when there was a lot of
resistance to the to militarism and much
of it was led by anarchists and this is
an anti anarchist film a bit of a
Content Advisory coming up this is newly
preserved
these are Wobblies
so this was a militaristic parade there
were a lot of objections to it there was
a bomb and two people associated with
the labor movement were arrested Tom
Mooney and Warren buildings later on
their cases were vacated but not after
not until after they most of them either
I think both of them had spent over 20
years in prison this was a big cause of
the American laughter and nobody knows
who who did this exactly now that's
mayor sonny jim Ralph this is April 1916
and it's a pro-war parade preparedness
day
this has been newly preserved by Library
of Congress
we've moved to the early 30s and you
will fondly remember these moving shots
of Chinatown time to change film
every year he keeps running
from what we don't know
the lineup outtake hang on
[Applause]
now we this was discovered in the
National Archives bike great Brecon
historian of the New Deal and many other
things and this is a film about the
federal theater project and this is the
Hippodrome in 35 or 36 I believe half
abandoned this is in Barbary Coast
Jackson Street
the man on the left is mr. yesan he ran
a advertising art and sign painting
company and it was a union shop and his
granddaughter has given us some
wonderful films since it was a union
shop he did work for a lot of the unions
and a jolly fellow there's his truck he
was on Stevenson Street here's some of
his work this is for all you I expect to
see these motifs in next year's graphic
design they specialized in these moving
billboards some of his crew
will you'll recognize that building at
Van Ness admission
if anybody recognizes any of these
streets
this was the Labour candidate
and this is the San Francisco Muni
marching band does this still exist it
should this is Labor Day and I believe
it's a composite of Labor Day 1939 and
1940 but think of San Francisco as a
Union town and there's these wonderful
thematic floats and this is of course a
demonstration of the force and the power
of Labor
what's interesting isn't just the
marchers it's the spectators because
there's quite a lot of them but the
yesand company made a lot of these
floats
they're stopping for a drink you'll see
some people in the you know their Labor
Day marching costumes having a quick one
so the ILWU was the union that organized
the longshore workers and then moved
inland to the warehouse workers it was a
union who had been built at the
beginning by many of them were communist
party members a strong progressive union
take a look at this abundance yet
scarcity this is Harry bridges and help
me with these other men if you know
Harry bridges was an Australian man
who
he worked the docks in San Francisco and
became very active in the early in
illegal organizing phases of this the
first longshore local this was a local
where the rank-and-file members voted on
all major decisions and around this time
the US government was trying to prove
that he was a communist and deport him
this is 1940 I think you can tell from
the Wilkey McNary campaign signs
right there was a newsreel theater
this I think is a Stewart Street outside
the longshore Union hiring hall at 113
Stewart if I'm not mistaken
it's mr. yesan shaking the hand that
feeds him
one of the most successful union
organizing situations in history and
corporations hated it these are the
white-collar unions most of which were
closed down after the world war two
because they were close to the Communist
Party the longshore dog
this was after the the Nazis and the
Soviets had signed a non-aggression pact
and before Pearl Harbor this is the rat
who's informing on Harry bridges it's a
Labor Day Parade
this is the late 30s and we're getting
on the ferry to go to Treasure Island in
a Treasure Island
it's the World's Fair there's some
silent footage here if you want to sing
over it
[Applause]
there's a train going by by the way key
system training it
this is Kodachrome which is very
saturated and so it has a particular
color scheme it's a little overexposed
in the center and underexposed in the
periphery a smart-looking family mom is
probably shooting if i'm not mistaken
I have heard that um it took the
exposition was really the was the first
time a lot of people actually took the
bridge
all color-coded concentric lot of paths
of concentric loops of color
entertaining and authentic the Gateway
a variety of attractions on the gay way
we've made this sequences shot here kind
of family-friendly so you won't see
everything I know be aware of anything
that's free on the Midway
I couldn't resist the beautiful
California pavilion
so Zoe Dell Lantis is a hundred years
old
today show her thought today this year
she was the theme girl of the fair she
became a pilot and she was she also ran
a technology company and was ahead of
the I think the first I have some notes
here the first woman president of the
National Aviation Hall of Fame
big bands and first-class entertainment
every day I believe that's Benny Goodman
this was considered you know a great
threat to the social order and it's time
jitterbugging there jitterbugging
sitting down
it's either on film or it isn't
daydreams right we've cut a little bit
here you'll cost you a dime to see
what's really going on
we could replicate this anywhere
the television one is interesting to me
and you have to look into that one
age-old drunkard
[Applause]
not uncensored than this this show this
is August 1941 the fair is gone but this
is the terminal for the the Pan Am
Clippers across the Pacific buildings
still there of course here's their
offices beautiful control tower
and this is clipper Cove I don't
remember the exact figures but the crew
on these flights came close in number
two the number of passengers and it was
I gather quite luxurious
three-day flight to Australia
this would be one answer to extending
the runways into Bay but I don't think
it would pass the environmental test
some tourists in 1944 still a fair
amount of cars out on the road a little
bit of working port here the obligatory
trip to the wharf and of course the
Instagram food pictures of the day what
is that
she seems tentative
this is the late 50s family poor quality
unfortunately but taking the
red-and-white Bay cruise
and traveling a little bit and this is
the yesan family out it by the Yacht
Club
no wave organ unfortunately at that
point
this is the late 30s
it's a slingshot
lovely Palace of Fine Arts inside
this is just as they shot at so if
there's a story there and this is from
the federal theater film they're playing
tennis inside the Palace of Fine Arts
and here there's some other people are
locked out of their car I just had to
leave this in
and from Twin Peaks a somewhat less
built out city
this is 1944 again
this is a film from roughly that same
period if you were to slow it down you'd
see some very very old houses in place
like that one this is um David Gallagher
has just researched this David what's
where are we and when keys are stadium
1939
[Applause]
our old DeYoung
was rebuilt at least twice so we've seen
our neighbors the G family from 15th
Avenue before but we haven't seen them
in high def than I found some new
material of them as well
the second chinese-american family to
move onto the block 15,000 you in the
Richmond District here he's delivering
the call bulletin and here where it's
stole a Keating those Betty Lou potato
chips popcorn excuse me of course
traffic accident in 15s in Balboa
happens all the time
and he's in the safety patrol going off
to
[Applause]
argon elementary school he's got company
in the 60s
I'm thinking that's when the saints go
marching in but I don't know
you have Oh outside line Hardly Strictly
Bluegrass Cathy gee
[Applause]
prom
and this is the snowfall of what was
this 62 this is the 60s later this is up
on you know bhaiyya the tower market oh
yeah
this is the the old car Barnes this is a
curving and Funston near andronicus well
it's the site of enter on it goes the
boneyard but it's a kind of a bit of a
place of wonder
when did we decide this was somewhere
around what 1947 ish is that right
right the big Irving theater sign in the
in the rear but we have fewer and fewer
of these spaces we're kind of you know
feral vegetation takes over
would heal abouty the author of Carville
by the sea is here to take questions
right this is the when's the lakeshore
Park neighborhood right
Inverness Avenue right after the war
I think there's somebody in the audience
who grew up near here
this is a streetcar railfan trip this is
in sometime in the early sixties
probably but I love that
and so the glider over the unbuilt
sunset about 1919 1920
but these are the early Avenue is one of
these days I promise it digital
restoration late fifties Sutro Baths
oh yeah the white tower gas station is
that what you said right dear we're
across from where seal Roxanne is now
hang on
so we've all seen footage of the Ohioan
and the Frank T buck wrecked off of
Lands End but one of the things that
only has become clear in this film from
a private collector that we scanned a
couple weeks ago
is that there was also a whale that was
washed up
and so here humans try to come to terms
with this animal
these wrecks were a huge tourist
attraction for a number of years they're
still visible pieces at low tide
in February 1938
making social trails
brief view of the short-lived skytram
and a wartime rainy day at the beach
these two fellas
a little bit of Playland
nobody's out and then slipping away from
us and rain and fog a little bit of
[Music]
Playland yes eight millimeter and eighth
and Harrison right but I the prey linger
library and here is where we take our
leave of San Francisco thank you
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]